Clash of Titans Clash of friends in this
one between yourself and leevon give us
the highlights of this game was it
difficult to defend against this
unexpected London let's
say I wasn't too surprised by the London
uh a little bit for sure but I thought
that the position was more or less close
to equal out of the opening maybe he was
a bit more familiar with it but uh but
certainly I shouldn't be so much worse
or anything at any moment maybe a tiny
bit worse and then I thought his move
Rook C1 was uh definitely quite har
quite harmless mhm after that I don't
think I have any issues and even at some
point I was pressing a bit maybe not too
much but I felt like I yeah Rook C1 I
thought okay H maybe H3 is better
instead ofly I don't have
any maybe H3 I mean it's it's not much
but what was your plan if you would have
went for H3 were you going to go for E5
what were you going for in this position
yeah here E5 doesn't work because Queen
B5 check comes and there's no Pawn H2
hanging so I can't do this but I can
well first first taking on E5 and then
Queen B5 yeah and take everything Queen
B5 wins the pawn so I can't do this
there's no more H2 yeah but I can play
H3 A6 for example I
can I can play Knight E4 also it's
definitely an interesting move I mean
few options yeah also Knight E4 is is
very tempting after h three so yeah I
don't know it's probably anyway a close
to even position I at some point you
even had more than equality in the
position you were the one that was
pressing at what point did you feel that
well in the end game I'm certainly
pressing with the pawn up but uh the the
pawn up might not be very much I mean I
I guess objectively it's always equal
but okay I'm the only one who can
potentially outplay him in this position
um and yeah I I thought maybe Rook C8
wasn't the most accurate
but uh but I guess it's it's always
always probably equal like maybe Knight
B6 instead of Rook C8
uh yeah this is Rook D4 Rook C8 e D5
Rook C5 yeah The Rook end game is
probably always a draw and I think he
would have gone for this Rook C5
D6 uh Rook B5 D7 yep but at least I get
A4 in and then he puts the Rook on A3
and yeah it's still a draw unfortunately
all rook and games are
drawn but but it was a bit of a better
chance perhaps no absolutely uh I would
say a positive result for you to start
off your campaign to defend the title
how are you feeling about your chances
how are you feeling about this
tournament what did you do in
preparation for this tournament as
well well it's been busy it's uh before
this tournament and I've had almost
non-stop chess for a while so I tried to
just take a little bit of a break um at
least get some a little break from chess
you know because the after the World Cup
there was also a bunch of online events
and the World Cup itself was of course
very very long although it's been it's
been quite a while since then but still
that was definitely a very um difficult
event for everyone who played and then I
had some online
events uh so so yeah it's been it's been
a busy period And I just wanted to rest
a little bit and hopefully I got some
rest I mean it's it's hard to say from
the first game of course especially
since it was a maybe not the most
eventful game but hopefully I'll have
energy for for this tournament because
it's going to be very long and and also
very difficult Fabby a quick question
for you we highlighted at the start of
the show that you are now you are now a
five-time candidate uh first of all
again congratulations how do you feel
about that accomplishment and
uh tell us uh what you're feeling
yeah no it's it's very good to be back
in the candidates but I don't view it as
an
accomplishment I think the
accomplishment comes when you win the
candidates so getting there of course is
difficult but it's really only the first
step uh in let's say a very difficult
three-step process and the second step
is perhaps the most difficult
one I think if we calculate like in
terms of equity probably the candidates
is the the least likely for someone to
uh to win to get to the next step even
compared to the match even though it's
like the final step there you only have
to compete with one other person and in
the candidates you have to compete with
seven other people so just by virtue of
that you're you're going to have uh the
most difficult time and I've I've only
managed to win the candidates One Time
by the skin of my teeth as well so it's
it's really tough um still I I am very
happy that I get the opportunity again
and I'm going to try to prepare really
hard and and do my best and do better
than last time thank you Fabby and
Christian I understand that things are
really heating up in the
hands